so we're gonna get started so part of
the reason why we even organized this
workshop was a collaboration with Pietro
Michael uchi from the human computation
Institute through some connections that
we made with the NSF big data hogs a
couple of years ago and we did a
workshop here in in redmond last october
maybe noticed that there were a few
projects franco pest erie from indiana
university he was one of the speakers
here today and Pietro and there was
another PI and we realized there was
this theme of crowdsourcing that was
emerging from some of our academic
collaboration so then we got together
and decided that we should probably you
know collaborate more with the research
that's going on in Microsoft research in
this area so yeah we look forward to
hearing what you have to say about this
okay
yeah thanks so much funny so it's it's
it's truly a pleasure to be here I mean
I I know a lot of you and and now I get
to meet some of you in person and and
hear more and see more about your what
your work and it's fascinating and one
of the things that that I've noticed and
so this this whole session is is
something like proud cloud and and the
future of Labor and and what I've
noticed is we're talking a lot about you
know how how do we insert humans in the
loop and create these human AI
partnerships so what is what is the
nature of the of the human involvement
and and so for me this was kind of an
indulgence this talk and and I I'm
hoping you'll join me in this indulgence
and we can and this can be a
conversation but but I'd like to sort of
shift us out of the space of of the the
sort of technical ways that we can we
can you know create these combinations
and think more about what we actually
should be doing and what the
implications of that are for the future
of labor and society so and and I want
to acknowledge my colleague eglim Maria
Romanowski Ida who actually created most
of the slides thank goodness so I'm
throwing a party tonight you're all
invited I'm making homemade sangria but
I have a teensy request which is that my
my neighbor really needs to get his lawn
mowed and I'm just hoping that that you
know maybe Lucy there's this one area in
the back of his lawn if you could just
mo that area I'd be happy to roll out
the carpet for you tonight and invite
you in for some sangria
so does that okay what do you think
uh-huh
so this this this model kind of happened
in a way right so I mean probably
everyone in the room you know has used
some version of this slide and in some
talk but you know most of the people who
participated in reCAPTCHA didn't realize
that they were providing labor there was
a quid pro quo like I want to get into
this website and if I this I get in but
they were helping to digitize back
issues archival issues of the New York
Times dating back to the 1800s
and and in that arc and that digitized
archive exists now and if you go ahead
has anyone here tried to go and look at
at those archived issues no so I haven't
I haven't either until last night when I
was thinking about this and it turns out
that you can but if you're not a
subscriber you have a limited amount of
access to it and not so limited in the
scope of what you can look at and how
many times you can look at it but you
know I was one of the people who filled
in these recaptures should I shouldn't I
be allowed to see all of it so
so something's changing there's
something new happening and and so
wikipedia defines the knowledge economy
as the use of knowledge to creates Goods
and goods and services this is a
buzzword you know it's used in a lot of
ways but I think what's upon us now is
is a thinking economy and that's eating
into the space of all the different
applications we're talking about today
and in other applications we haven't
discussed and so I would say you know if
I had to make up a definition what do I
mean by the thinking economy it's the
use of information processing to solve
problems so humans are information
processors machines or information
processors bacteria are information
processors and and an economy isn't just
about money right I mean when I hear
economy I think money but it's really
it's about supply and demand and
exchange of Labor and goods or labor for
labor so there you know there are
implications of this shifting to a
valuation of information processing and
so so yeah this is a well-known led
zepplin quote and it's kind of
tongue-in-cheek because you know yes
there are two paths we can take there
multiple paths we can take and and I
would argue that changes are happening
around us and we need to start thinking
about these things in deciding now we
can't we can't wait so does anyone has
anyone here heard of multiple universe
multiverse theory sure yeah well yeah
let's see of course there are an
infinite number of lucy's that's a
wonderful thing and and so there's a
version of our universe and in this in
this theory that includes every possible
outcome and there's indeed a universe in
which I could to spend weekends playing
chess with my buddy bill unfortunately I
don't live in that particular universe
but whether you believe in infinite
universes or not there are infinite
possibilities
for our future right and our labor
economy our society our culture and and
human civilization itself is Co evolving
with technology and we have no idea
where we're gonna be in 20 years there
are lots of opinions but we really don't
know but the good news is we can
influence that and that's what I'm
really interested in thinking about and
talking about together but the only way
that we can understand where we are
sorry the only way we can we can
influence that in ways that are
meaningful to us is to understand where
we are today where we want to be in the
future and then try to figure out what
are the intermediate steps to get there
right basic stuff so where are we today
well some of you probably remember the
dot-com bubble I would say we're in the
middle of an AI bubble that would
probably provoke some interesting
conversations with some people and you
know AI is great I love AI and machine
learning is more practical than ever
thanks mostly to Moore's law but also to
some clever innovations nai is getting
better but it's not really putting
people out of work what it's doing is
it's changing the kind of work that
people do but AI is going to continue to
get better and we need to be ready for
that
so what does that mean what does it mean
to be ready
how does shifting to an economy in which
human information processing is highly
valued how does that create an
opportunity today for us to build a
future we want to live in so we have to
decide together what this future will
look like and then figure out step by
step how to get there and we might not
figure out all the steps at once okay
but what's the next step what should we
be doing now so yesterday my weekend
chess buddy bill in my dreams brought up
something really important in a really
clever way he said an email tends to not
be a random message going to a random
person and this is this is the context
issue of course right and and and it
reminded me of my new uninvited Gmail
bot that tries to tell me what I should
be saying when I'm typing an email I get
an email it reads the email I got and
then it tells me what I should say back
this is very unnerving and very
uncomfortable by the way for me
personally and and I and I have these
and it gets me into these like endless
infinite horrible loops of well that's
not exactly the way I would say it but
jeez is that better than the way I would
say it or that's exactly what I was
gonna say which makes me want to do
something different you know who's this
machine to be guessing is it is it
studying me how does it know I would say
that and and human communication social
communication is extremely nuanced and
and I might not realize what I'm doing
but I feel like the way I communicate
has been effective and now I feel like
it's being changed without my consent
and you know so this kind of illustrates
this idea yeah my colleague found this
well so you know contact context is
obviously everything and and when we can
see telltale signs of trouble like this
I think we need to call them call them
out and head them off
so you know and and AI quite frankly
sucks at context I'm just gonna say it
and that's why we need humans in the
loop so so this is one way that humans
add value I think in terms of
information processing and maintaining
human representation in the broad space
of thinking
helps ensure that we have a say in what
happens next
so by inserting humans in the loop today
and being part of these information
processing systems that have many
automated components we can remain
influential and there's another aspect
of this which is that you know the the
the holy grail for generalized AI is to
achieve human-like intelligence we have
human-like intelligence
it's called humans and and what we
really need to solve today's problems
and tomorrow's problems is superhuman
intelligence so and and and I believe
the only way to achieve that at least
today is with humans in the loop
and I think it'll be that way for some
time so I want to tell you about some
human-in-the-loop approaches and how
they're shaping our future so three
years ago my colleagues and I created an
online game called Stoll catchers that
anyone can play and by playing stock
catchers you help accelerate Alzheimer's
disease research and we ran a team
competition it was a month-long
competition to test our new team feature
and and and so this this Lake Hazel
middle school in Boise Idaho created a
team of 250 students that were extremely
competitive and and it was a
neck-and-neck competition with the
retirement community until literally the
very last day of the competition when
the teacher held a pizza party and
invited her kids in her students in on a
Saturday to win and they did win the
competition so I felt compelled to go
out and thank them in person I gave him
the first citizen-science
trophy which sits in the case next to
the football trophy and and then and
they had an assembly and and I got to
speak with them and and thanked them and
and recognize their contribution and I
said you might think I'm here to tell
you all to become scientists said I
don't care if you become a scientist or
not I just want you to recognize that
you used science to solve a problem it's
a tool and it's a powerful tool and it's
the best tool we have today to solve
problems and you did it you know and
someday you're gonna tell your
grandchildren you know who
there there there AR there
augmented-reality
you know glasses on and there they're
doing all kinds of cognitive labor
you're gonna say I was there at the
beginning you know we started this
hopefully they don't hate you so in 2014
I I organised with some colleagues
workshop at the Wilson Center called the
human computation roadmap summit some
people here were there Paul Bennett who
was in the room a minute ago was there
and Steven Dao who's in this picture was
there and we had so the purpose of the
summit was to say what are the new
capabilities we can create with humans
in the loop and what are the research
areas that need to be pursued in order
to achieve those human-in-the-loop
capabilities what's the missing research
and what are the applications so we had
breakout groups and this group was about
the future of work and and so you know
Steven and Marcus Kraus came up with
this idea that they called pathways to
radiology and the idea is that you you
know you're you you do it kind of like
as a volunteer in citizen science you
get these radiographs and and you help
do a diagnosis you say I think there
might be cancer there's a big splotch in
the middle this lung you know could be a
problem and then you a grenade it in and
then over time you know you're measuring
expertise and these people become
certified based on the skill that they
demonstrate in the system and once
they're certified maybe they start
getting paid for it and then you take
only the most challenging ones the ones
where there's the most disagreement as
in viswas you have the most disagreement
among all these sort of public
volunteers or paid certified workers so
then you give those to the expert to the
radiologist you're making the best use
of the radiologist time because the
radiologist is only focusing on the ones
that require that level of expertise so
something really cool happened doesn't
happen very often but something that an
idea in a workshop turned into
actual platform and so Marcus Kraus took
this idea a level further and he he
wrapped MOOCs into it so people are
studying and businesses are providing
datasets to support these MOOCs people
are doing crowd based analysis on the
data their performance is being
monitored they're learning in exchange
for this at the end of it they have a
credential which is their performance on
the data set which becomes part of the
resume that goes to the organization
that delivered the data and they hire
them as employees and they've had
several successful examples of this
where people now are cognitive laborers
because of having gone through this MOOC
process so someone mentioned this
earlier I think a che maybe mentioned
inert octave so you know driverless cars
so nice does everyone know about how
Nissan handles the driverless car
problem no okay so this is really cool
if there's an article in Wired magazine
so the idea is that when a car gets into
a tricky situation that it can't handle
it calls a human-powered call center and
then all the cartel and tree goes to the
call center and then the you know the
person either either you know comment
ears the car or sends the right data
back so the car knows how to get out of
the sticky situation so people who used
to drive cars around now work at the
call center solving the problems that
the cars can't solve so this is kind of
I think this is a very interesting and
example of the shift in how how labor
happens because of what we're able to do
with with automation and and it raises
you know these ethical issues that I
think that was the part that was an AJ's
talk which is you know kind of the idea
that that if you're a human driving a
car and you get into a sticky situation
you have you know 1/100 of a second to
make all kinds of ethical moral
decisions about who do I know do I go
through the shop window and I don't know
if there are people there or do I hit
this little pedestrian over here but now
we have to actually figure those things
out and build them into the systems so
okay I see I'm kind of running short on
time so anyway bottom line is we need to
decide together you know what this
future will look like and figure out
step by
how to get there so what's the next step
you know after these systems that we
have today well it's I think it's the
work that many of you have already
described in stock catchers where we're
also experimenting with these
human-in-the-loop or I'm sorry with
human AI partnerships as part of the
citizen science platform so we install
catchers the basic it's a simple binary
classification task you have to decide
if a blood vessel is flowing or stalled
we draw an outline around it but who
draws the outline well we we actually we
have an algorithm now that does that
that is based on work done by eye wire
and then extended by a member of our
team so that's completely automated some
of our movies are bad there's an outline
but there's no vessel in it so we have
to find those well we we have humans
flagging those but we also are building
a machine classifier to find those as
well and of course the human data the
human flagging data is helping to feed
into that but that's not an automated
process and I think that's an important
point you know we take a data set and we
bring it over here we put it in the
machine owner and we train it and then
it gives us an output and it's pretty
good and yeah but it's not quite good
enough and when it is will eventually
hook it into the system but there's all
this manual connecting of things and I
think that's a big problem I think
that's one of the stepping stones and
then and then the main thing that humans
do is classify the vessels so if if the
answer were in the pixels then the
machine would be doing it but machines
are only 85% accurate because there's
context required there's knowledge of
physics so so I think you know we're
working toward more elaborate systems
more complex systems we need tools to
get there and ultimately you know you
could say you know every every you know
what you when you're at an AI workshop
it's all about how do we build the best
day I you know or you know when you're
you're at a DARPA sponsored thing it's
Hannah how do we hold the next best
thing to give us an advantage over our
adversaries but what if we just pop up
above all these levels and say what do
we
really want to do here well wouldn't it
be interesting if the you know the earth
system becomes a massive super
prediction model that basically self
adapts and maintains homeostasis kind of
has an organism and I and I feel like
that's that's one trajectory and maybe
that's not the best thing but sometimes
it helps to have a light in the distance
to aim for so a few stepping stones that
I'm just going to put out there but
humans in the right part of the loop
prepare our children for the thinking
economy reinvent equitable reward
systems and importantly create tools for
studying humans in the loop that give us
the ability to reuse and extend the work
that we've done to share datasets to
share algorithms and to work together
more fruitfully so our vision is
evolving and in the end I have no idea
what the future should actually look
like but I think we want to make sure
that we keep humans in the driver's seat
in the ways that matter most thank you
[Applause]
questions not just questions I want to
know your vision for the future okay
very visionary great talk and I'm gonna
ask little bit of details about what
your thinking should be we should go for
the next thing I mean money introduced
how we've been talking for a while about
the possibilities and the problems that
some of the the new platforms are
generating and what do you think your
from your point of view the intersection
between the other talks we've seen today
I and the human contribution should be
well what are the opportunities that
were missing now like what are the what
Alzheimer's one what else would you go
for and what are the low-hanging fruits
that you would address Oh the problems
that we can solve for enemies with these
methods yeah so I mean we we have we
have a lot more experience today than we
did five ten years ago with with micro
tasking and what's exciting about some
of the work I've seen today is is that
I'm seeing pipeline processes where
humans intervene at different levels in
the process I don't think we've
exhausted micro tasking or versions of
that for solving problems particularly
in the health space and I think in in
those context it's it's I think the work
that's being done today that's been
described that explores kind of the best
ways to manage these the most effective
ways to manage these partnerships in
terms of the pre-processing algorithms
that massage the data and put it in a
form that's really kind of a place to
the strengths of human perception and
cognition so so I think you know we're
thinking about use cases now in in
life-threatening arrhythmias in macular
degeneration studies and in diagnosing
kidney disease and and and and lots of
other kind of health-related areas and
you know my lens is kind of on that
because of the work we've been doing but
I think the space is wide open and I
think there's so much interesting work
to be done also in education and and I
didn't really talk much about that side
of it but but I think there's a you see
a lot of informal learning going on
as people participate in these systems
and we have you know we have graphs that
show increases quantitative and
qualitative increases in knowledge and
capability and the people who
participate in stall catchers you just
mentioned like heart arrhythmias or
other sorts of medical are you imagining
that crowd workers could be used for
sort of real-time diagnosis or detection
or to help those sorts of things or is
it still more on those sort of labeling
or on the research side I I would say
yes to both in in a sense so what I mean
by that is that depending on the
application I think you know there are
some cases in which it's it's just its
labeling and then it's it's advancing
research their clinical their direct
real-time clinical applications or or
clinician supported applications I think
that can they can also be pursued and
and I think the tricky area there goes
back to this this whole you know my
little google friend that tells me what
I should be saying that you know when
the clinician is sitting there and the
AAI says well you know I really think
this is this and I really think you
should give this treatment and the
clinicians like geez you know that
wasn't what I was really gonna say but
now that you mention it well you might
be right you know and causes this kind
of how do we yeah how do we I that's a
very challenging space to tackle I think
that's the space you're tackling yeah I
guess the crowd could be like the
lifeline and in the millionaire maybe I
could have an expert and a crowd and and
my own opinion like yeah I think that's
a really interesting model to explore
and I think again having a platform that
enabled that makes it easy to stand up
models like that and play with them and
test them out could be really useful so
you know we're certainly looking at use
cases where we want to have real time we
want to have a machine based system
that's doing a kind of an evaluation
that's related to to to to to a health
topic except that we can't fully trust
the Machine so how does the machine
how do we set a threshold on the machine
to say you know I'm really not sure
about this people need to look at it and
then send that to the crowd so that's I
think one version of that yeah so next
up we have Lucy Watson from University
of Minnesota we are running behind
schedule which is going to take time out
of the breakout session and then we also
have lunch scheduled as part of the
workshop so we can continue talking
through lunch if people want to keep
talking things I have to hold it I don't
have pockets yeah okay I think it's on
the right okay perfect okay
and I've been in stem and ER so I will
do my best you can just you know signal
me to go all right so so this is great
Pietro set some fantastic vision and I'm
gonna get down into the weeds a little
bit more and tell you about the
Zooniverse platform and what we're doing
both on the machine side but also trying
to understand our volunteers and you
know since this is sort of future of
work and some of us are volunteers
without even knowing that we're
volunteers and we capture every single
time I do recapture I had to do it last
night
I'm like come on you know identify the
chimneys isn't that obvious that I'm
giving you my my labor so so volunteers
what motivates the volunteers to
participate and how can we best combine
human and machine intelligences together
and so I really like this concept of
sort of help me to help you so you know
well who is the subject in this right is
it the Machine asking the human or is it
the human asking the machine but so
that's sort of the the set up there all
right so firstly I I think a number of
people know about suniverse but I just
feel like I
to give some grounding and and what it
is so it started with the Galaxy Zoo
project in 2000 2007 and we'll come back
to Galaxy Zoo a bit later we currently
have a little bit over 1.75 million
volunteers worldwide over 150 projects
as of last night 432 some odd nearly
four hundred thirty three million
classifications and one of the things
that we try to make sure differentiates
us from other citizen science projects
and this isn't a value statement I have
to be very careful to say it is just
what we feel we should be providing is
scientific outcomes so we do require
that the science teams that work with
our platform do their best to obtain at
least one peer-reviewed published paper
out of the data that they have collected
from the citizen scientists otherwise as
other people have alluded to it's kind
of a waste of volunteer effort and the
volunteers like to see they know kind of
what the currency of the realm is in in
the scientific disciplines they know
peer-reviewed papers are important and
so they like to see that their data have
been used in peer-reviewed papers and
we'll come back to this topic in a
little bit as well and so yeah you can
play the game of what the you know total
gain if you will is to the to the system
based on the volunteer work force and so
we have a project page you can go in and
you can you know filter by discipline
you can a filter by most recently
launched by the project that needs the
most help by you know of a variety of
different filters to get to the project
that you would choose to work on and so
these are the different types of tasks
you know we started a long time ago you
can you know you know over 12 years ago
now building up a repertoire of sort of
tasks ma
Jools things that we found different
science teams required and we abstracted
them to specific types types of tasks
which of course can be used and
different disciplines and this is you
know just a couple of examples so this
is a marking task and this is just the
UI that the volunteer sees and this is a
freehand draw tool you know of course
this is something that a machine finds
very difficult and this is a survey task
we have a lot of camera-trap projects
where you want to identify specific
animals and the images and you can reuse
that same type of infrastructure the
tool the survey tasks to do a
gravitational wave categorization
problem - so that's just to show that
these these underlying tools are generic
in that sense and so of course we can
also do annotation or transcription so
those are just a few of the types of
examples we have then as many have
alluded to I think most people in this
room know how this work but just to go
through it so the idea is you know many
brains make light work you need to
develop a consensus of all the different
labels that have been provided through a
given task or workflow and you know
several people have alluded to already
this is where a lot of optimization can
be done how many people do you actually
need to tell you if a spiral galaxy is a
spiral galaxy do you need one two five a
hundred well of course that depends on
the difficulty of the of the image and
you know as people have said how you
phrase the question and the context and
the information that the people bring to
the problem at the end of the day
however you do get a consensus answer
which the science team then uses for
their hopefully
vacations so this is just to sort of
show the impact which is pretty
impressive this comes out of a Watson
flirty review of a large number of
Zooniverse projects and then just
compares you know this is the citation
percentile of 62 of the data sets of
publications that were used by
Zooniverse compared to the 5500
publications that use the very same
publicly available datasets and they're
you know just the the density
distribution of citations and the
importance and relevance of the of the
papers that have been produced through
the Zooniverse work as compared to the
generic scientist not using the citizen
science method so how do we enable
research teams to use our platform well
in 2015 we launched a project builder in
which you can sign in and very easily
put together a project we have sort of
three basic ways people use the system
predominantly it's you know this
intention is to launch a project that
the general public has access to it goes
through a beta testing phase where we
have a hundred thousand peers signed up
to actually do beta testing they get
feet
the research team gets feedback and then
they use that feedback to improve their
project before they actually launch it
live the second way is you can have
let's say you may have a small data set
10,000 images or something like that
it doesn't make sense to launch it to a
large volunteer audience and maybe you
have a set of undergrads for the summer
that you just want to gather some labels
on something and you can just use the
URL to pass it around your team and then
the third way
if you have privacy issues human
research issues and you need to have it
behind the firewall so at the end of the
day this is our you know our growth over
time we started off in in in space I'm
an astrophysicist yes I know what a
multiverse is do I believe that they
actually exist why not you know
everything comes down to the quantum
foam right but so you can see that we're
beginning to be dominated by our ecology
projects right now you know the
astrophysicists amongst us are you know
you know keep trundling along but and
we're moving more into and we hope to
continue to move more into the
biomedical areas and other areas but so
this is you can see the launch of the
project builder basically our you know
growth sort of exploded at that point
and I just want to point out this is not
a cumulative distribution this is the
number of projects launched per year and
I could show you a different graph which
is some of these projects of course
finish within maybe two months some of
them stay live for over a year or more
or three years or something so if I did
do a cumulative distribution it would be
even more impressive okay so where are
we going where are we been where are we
going so Galaxy Zoo the context in which
Galaxy Zoo was launched there was the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey that had a
million images that needed to be
classified and this was a research
project for one graduate student and and
so back in the bad old days of 2007 when
deep learning wasn't really a thing and
you know big data was actually spelled
with a little B in a little D you know a
million galaxies that was a lot but you
could actually get the volunteers to go
through each one of them okay yeah and
that was great it was awesome
and it was good and and those of us who
started the whole you know project you
know we realized we were on this wave
you know writing this wave that was just
you know only getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and so now we're at this
point where instead of the Sloan Digital
Sky Survey with 1 million galaxies we
have the large synoptic survey telescope
which is going to generate 20 billion
galaxies it doesn't matter how many
people you recruit to the platform that
is just not going to happen so citizen
science and this needs machine learning
but as many people have pointed out you
need both the humans and the machines
you can't just hand over the all the
data to to the machines even if you have
a few labels provided by the humans it's
not just astronomy
this is our first camera trap project in
the Serengeti launched in 2012 7 million
images just for the first six seasons
launched in 2012 this is our growth in
camera trap projects boy people thought
that was a great idea you know they
jumped on the system and again with the
project builder it made it very very
easy for a research team to put together
a a survey project so how are we going
to introduce machines into the system
then so one of the ways that you could
do it okay so you've got all these data
and you can you know get clever people
to train machines for you to in the
first instance eliminates the empty
images
okay so images that do not have a animal
in them and so if you trust your machine
completely okay but machines as we've
just heard me you know they make
mistakes so what you really want is you
want a system whereby you have a machine
predicting an image to be
empty but then you actually need just
maybe one or two or five validations
from humans so again this is all about
retiring subjects we call the images in
the system a subject retire subjects
faster so you just use a threshold on
your confidence score you have the you
know after you put the data through the
machine model you upload to the
Zooniverse then you use this what we
call a cascade filtering workflow so you
recognize that a binary question whether
it's empty or not is actually easily
done on our mobile app because people
are standing in line at Starbucks you
know they're bored okay so they
tenderized whether or not there's a
animal in the image or not so so that we
found actually works very well and then
we can move images that do have an
animal in them into well then you can
like in some cases or vehicles but
eventually you move them into the
workflow which is really just
identifying the species and in this
experiment which was published by a
graduate student of mine where do i oh
my god it's Willy at all why do I not
have him up here that's bad okay so
anyways we found that 43 percent fewer
volunteer classifications were required
to keep you know assuming same accuracy
okay
so that's the simple way you can
introduce machines under the system you
can get really complicated if you want
and really you know super clever this is
worked by mike walmsley from the Oxford
crew of suniverse
this is in fact what is now live on the
galaxy zoo system and this is an active
learning algorithm in which using
informatics information theoretic
methods the machine learns
to figure out which image is the next
best image to get a human label on and
ask at present that image to the next
person and I see my time is up
and I'm only partly done I will do my
best to go fast so this is the list of
all of the different ways that we can
incorporate machine learning onto the
system but the problem is is that a lot
of our science teams don't necessarily
have the background on how to implement
machine learning so we're actually
collaborating with Microsoft right now
with AI for earth and Dan Morris & Co to
try to find a way to offload the
responsibility from the Zooniverse
platform and get people to people such
as ecologists who may not be good at
machine learning and Microsoft provides
that service and so trying to find a way
to enable that service okay so why do we
need human still well we have this thing
called is real a problem lurking in all
of these images there can be very rare
species so that the data set is
unbalanced that's a Zorrilla for those
of you who didn't know what is it real
it was before only seven out of ten
million images contain a Zorilla
very unbalanced data set so this also
leads to the point that discoveries can
be made by humans sure machines can make
discoveries but humans have that innate
ability to ask what the hell is this and
so this is just a collection of several
of the discoveries that have been made
and now we want to get into the whole
volunteer side why our humans motivated
to to participate on this our volunteers
feel that contributing to research is
what they would like to do and this is
just sort of a distribution of the
I'm sorry the map doesn't show up very
well but it's you know basically in
english-speaking countries as it turns
out although we do have a translation
service on our on our platform as well
so this is sort of the the age breakdown
and I'm gonna fly through these since
I've run out of time already you can see
that we do have you know we're pretty
highly educated which isn't too much of
a surprise and we have a high well
relatively high number of retired people
but again a large number that are
employed and we know that the
distribution of employment is everything
from a somebody who stalks who's a
stalker
at a pet store some food supplier all
the way up to lawyers and doctors and
astronomers and whatnot so a full range
we also survey ways in which people get
to the Zooniverse platform and you know
this was quite interesting to us we
actually thought a lot of it was word of
mouth there is a lot of word of mouth we
also thought broadcast mania but what
was heartening for us is that people
just sort of stumble on it okay so a
couple of things that we've learned
along the way
people don't like competition on the
Zooniverse okay this is not necessarily
a surprise to some social scientists but
they did definitely not want to see
leaderboards and we found that out in
some sense the hard way this is also
just to show that most of our projects
have the sort of a classic Gini
coefficient range and a distribution
sort of a classic distribution of the
you know sort of that's Pareto or power
law most people provide a few number of
classifications early on in the lifetime
of a project except for the supernova
hunter project in which
the data was released weekly and this
turned out to be our most biased gender
sample of volunteers mostly skewing
towards the male population and highly
educated and we feel that this may have
something to do with the competition
aspect of knowing that there's going to
be a release of data and they want to
get on the system to get the to discover
the new super supernova hunters we found
you know that people wanted more ways to
track progress they wanted reminders
when projects needed help so the way we
created new ways of engagement on
individual landing pages and also at the
project level and finally sorry I really
went over time so the one of the most
important things was that they wanted to
have more engagement with scientists and
this just shows the with several metrics
that show public engagement versus
contribution to science that it's the
projects where the science teams
actually engage the most with the
volunteers that actually contribute to
science the most as well so that's
actually incredibly important takeaway
message that humans are really
complicated so if you want to add
machines and humans together I don't
have time to go into what that means but
we all need to keep in mind that the
human is a complicated machine if you
will so we have to keep that in mind and
how do we message to the volunteers that
they're working alongside machines and
how that actually changes their response
and so I'll just leave it at that how to
best optimize this platform to give the
best human-machine partnership for
science discovery so thanks and I
apologize for going over time thank you
[Applause]
so should we move on to the last talk
and then we can take questions maybe at
the end hi I'm here thanks for inviting
me it fantastic has been fantastic three
days four for me to experience
everything Microsoft is doing and also
I'm fascinated to be I believe one of
the only neuroscientists in the room and
it's been happening for some time to me
because I've been working on platforms
and in the computer science world and
engineering words so I'm here today to
present brain life the platform that
we've been working on it for a couple of
years now
we've been receiving funding since
September 2017 initially NSF and now
also we got ads or credits to do some
computing I will give you a two-minute
short version on neuroscience we're
trying to address many questions in your
science the ideas to understand and
improve human health and there's
questions in neuroscience that address
issues such as how do we make decisions
how do we make decisions now how do we
save our life why did them that choice
made a turn right or left
and those are those are events in our
life that happens in milliseconds to
seconds but but there's also questions
that we're trying to address that deal
with very long term processes such as
aging happening now to all of us and
development they used to happen to us a
long time ago and for all these type of
processes you can imagine there has to
be different types of measurements and
data that we need to acquire indeed
neuroscientists have developed over the
years many types of data this is a plot
that goes from time on these axes and
size on these axes these are scales of
measurements you know in neuroscience we
have measurements that are as small of a
synapse you know the connection between
two neurons and but some measurements go
all the way to the whole brain we can
measure from milliseconds all the way to
days
month but each one of these square is a
different type of measurements and these
measurements are different they provide
different types of data some data is
electrical data by electrical activity
in the brain some data is imaging data
like biomedical imaging data and they
all provide a different view different
windows are calling them here on the
brain so some of some of these
measurements are pretty good at
addressing questions such as decisions
and fast-acting a bands over life turns
out those measurements are best suited
for measuring in animal models in humans
they're invasive they're fast resolution
and high resolution other measurements
are better suited for humans they're not
invasive and they give you a different
type of data and also different types of
scale different windows on the brain the
work I'll present later mostly will
focus on this human side even though we
are actually working on other side so
this is a landscape of the brain data
that we can currently collect and we
currently collecting across the world
and that's what I want to go next
across the world it turns out even
though this is not a picture of what I'm
not talking about couldn't find a
picture there's a uneven distribution of
data being collected across the US and
across the world there are some parts of
the world that are really good at
collecting some type of data and other
parts of the world that are not there's
other parts of the world or institutions
that are really good at computing or a
software but other institutions are
really good at neuro science
neuroscience Anatomy or neuroscience
function okay and historically this has
not this landscape has not been
addressed within within neuroscience
well one way to think about these
measurements is that this is a what I
call an old picture in neuroscience we
used to look at pictures like this were
fundamental for us to understand how the
brain and other we must organize how the
small cells inside the brain and make
you think we're structured and connected
to each other and but like with all
these measurements
what we really do we were incurring into
a process or digitisation of the human
brain function and structure and one
thing that happened with digital is that
digital goes to scale and that's an
opportunity that is just becoming real
in the last maybe 10 15 years
neuroscientists have been acquired tons
of data and computing moore's law
introduced before by pietro is helping
us we are in the position now start
asking questions that are the scale
across population that hasn't been
addressed before now I told you before
different institutions different regions
different states different counties are
much better at some part of neuroscience
ok and but at the at the end of the day
to do research once the data are
collected there's three main axes that
have to come together to actually
analyze the data the code software the
data the actual collection of data done
in different institution and computing
and these three axes are not trivial for
many of you that's why I'm not trivial
from the department's were being hanging
out psychology and neuroscience
you had to put together the computer
with the right hardware the right size
you install the software packages you
need so that the software works you need
to connect to the right lab to get the
data etc etcetera there's a lot of human
intervention in all these steps give you
an example on my experience so that's
then my graduate students started about
four years ago it's about to graduate
and I worry many of you have graduate
students worried about him leaving the
lab and leaving some software somewhere
on the computer and I don't know what
that software does anymore and he goes
and gets a company job maybe I'm
Microsoft and then what right and five
years a colleague calls me oh I really
like your work and I would like to use
it can you share the code and I'm like
ok that's right Sandra is a different
experience she's a fascinating
collaborator she's interested in the
human eye she
yes data from the human eye and wants to
understand how reduced vision impacts
the brain this is something we don't
think about the my lab is working
actively right
when we lose vision the reduce inputs
actually changes your brain and we're
just trying to understand we've done
some fascinating studies trying to
understand how that changes your brain
and what type of processes are initiated
so Santa comes to my lab and we work and
I teach her something goes back to her
lab and try to struggle installing
everything she's in a clinical context
okay she doesn't have engineer and
software engineers around she has to
struggle with the software Martha is the
opposite cookie na I want to work with
Martha like I want to York with you guys
I want people that know machine learning
I have data were collecting data were
gathering data we want to do smart
things on this data so Martha is a
computer scientist and we're working on
trying to understand completely new ways
of formulating how we structure brain
data so that we can do better machine
learning on it Lior is a different
collaborator he's in a small College no
PhDs
okay they teach image processing and
engineering but they had no neuroscience
project right can we bring neuroscience
to Lear and students can we have each
student contribute to neuroscience in a
different way and then there's hardly
she's also collaborate oh we're trying
to understand stroke we're trying to
understand how stroke my spare part of
our abilities when that happens which
circuits of the brain are still
connected when after a stroke you
recover better than other people
and that's me and the way I do this I
collaborate I call us and emails I use
memy technology like slackin team and I
go on and on and on a do all this work
for every one of these collaborators
there's data as computing an algorithm
need to make sure that they're using the
right data files the one we agreed on
the right algorithms versions etc etc
and they had to reinstall everything
every time they move well because of
these we started working and because of
issues like this we started working on a
project called brain
laughter yo this is a platform that it's
supposed to bring together collaborative
efforts from different institutions from
different fields of science the platform
provides basic mechanisms for
registering and analysis a piece of
machine learning code or a piece of
analysis that we do in pre-processing on
these images it becomes an app on the
platform the bit can be reused and I'll
show you a little bit later datasets can
be uploaded on the platform like many
other platforms do and their register in
such a way that the platform understand
what type of data set is and what type
of apps can act on these data sets so
there's a little bit of intelligence
that we're building into the platform so
the apps and data interact with each
other and the other thing that we care
because we were funded you know publicly
funded and we're a research enterprise
here so we actually put a lot of effort
in making sure that the backhand or the
computing side was flexible so we can
actually handle different different
architecture HPC or cloud systems can
all run and we can be on different cloud
system so now we are on jet stream which
is an NSF cloud system the first we are
on Azure and we're also running on
several HPC clusters from different
University there are partners so what
this means is that we're pushing data
taking data from different clusters and
different institutions and doing
analysis where it's most convenient the
platform keeps care of efficiency or the
art on different systems as a priority
set inside so we kind of know a little
bit about where we should be processing
the data if the platform
if the compute system is available and
the apps are basically get up
repositories very lightweight it's your
code it's everyone's code with a little
bit of a requirement that the platform
needs to read from a JSON file write to
a JSON file the outputs and almost like
that obviously it's always more
complicated and like that but it is very
as simple as that apps can be devised or
will use singularity so that we can run
them on cloud and HPC or it can be you
can be Python code or
MATLAB code actually we have some
licenses on the public cloud that allow
us to run license code like MATLAB and
so these are the clouds that we do with
me as I said we use mix of systems and
the platform supposed to help the
scientist manage this whole complex
workflow supposed to help you know which
data you're computing where they are and
sunder your project etc etc so what are
the goals of the project well we're
trying to enhance the work of scientist
right we're trying to improve the way
the cut the normal workflow of scientist
happens things end on a desk or under a
desk on a hard drive and there's really
hard to track provenance of data and
code we're trying to connect different
communities try and create opportunities
for more computer scientists to come and
analyze data or try their algorithms
we're trying to promote at the same time
sharing data because we believe there's
questions we're not addressing in
neuroscience because of the lack of
volume in data there's question that
require understanding by the ability
across measurements device and
institutions areas in the world and
populations that we cannot currently
address also we try and top cycle the
long tail of data right most type most
data and neuroscience gets collected for
study or two or three or four and then
disappears that data could be very
useful for developing a denoising
algorithm for examples to know that some
algorithms are good fit for low quality
data all better for high quality etc so
that's what the process we call
upcycling and that's the first paper we
publish describing part of the platform
and I'll give you sense of what we're
doing if you come to the platform and
use the apps that the platform has and
if you use some data or import your data
you are actually allowed by the platform
to publish in a single record with a
single digital object identifier all the
workflow all the objects all the assets
generated so I think I have a little
video verse okay so that's the landing
page we're entering now the platform
there's an app there's a project area
this all the project that I can see some
of them are private some of them are
public these are the apps the apps look
like any other app store even though
this is all free there's a publication
page and now we have a few publication
coming up the first one is this the one
I project this publication is a single
rack of through a DOI has instruction
how to download the data how to
reference the data who was involved in
this project and the release does
multiple release there are snapshots of
data has been changing over time as what
we call data types data type for example
freesurfer is very common in
neuroscience everyone knows what
freesurfer is it's an anatomical analyze
data set and you can look at it so this
is our data set look it's a visual
interface to allow to run here common
software this is not our software here
the visualization is from Harvard MGH
and and at the same time there's a
different data set that I'm coming over
to give you a sense you can download the
whole provenance of this data set these
are all the apps related to this data
set that they they up suggest and this
is all that happened to that data set to
initial data sets this is all the apps
that were used to generate the blue data
set at the bottom and the apps are
registered all the way down to the git
commit so that you can go back and
reconstruct now I like what Lucy was
saying before we actually have the same
philosophy here where we are trying to
develop the platform in a way that is
useful to scientists so we actually
haven't published a full description on
the platform because everyone that we
have on the platform now is trying to do
science on it okay and it's coming it's
coming together
so this is Ben then just publish the
paper using the platform in which he
identifies new relatively on an
undescribed brain connection these are
major tracks that go from the top
your brain in the back to the bottom
connect parietal cortex to hood
areas that look and recognize objects
this is a brad another student in the
lab and neko as a collaborator were
working on some sport concussion related
studies we're looking at property of the
microstructure of cortex the surface of
the brain and we're looking at property
of the major highways of the brain these
brain connections that we all know a
name and we try to identify early
biomarker for CTE like track with the
idea can we identify different type of
individuals that might be more at risk
for developing CTE later in life and
we're using machine learning to do some
classification where different groups of
participant estin different models
things that you guys are pretty good at
right and and that actually very
exciting results here we would put 90
percent performance and some of the
classification this is lindsay another
graduate student lindsay has been
looking at a relatively unexplored
aspects of the brain shape she's using
Laplace Beltrami operators very simple
3d way of describing adding features
that describe complex 3d shapes so
lindsay takes highways of the brain to
have these canonical shapes that
everyone are that's the arcuate
fasciculus looks like a banana connects
you from here to here in your brain and
it's actually fundamental for reading
and language okay and what we're doing
we're looking at populations of
individual like thousands of individuals
looking at the variability in the shape
so what we do with the laplace Beltran
we try to reconstruct the shape of these
tracks
these are differents trucks the original
these are different say parameters in
the model low parameters modeled bandeau
very well the reconstructing better
higher parameters model reconstruct the
shape much better we know a certain
point we can cross validate how many
models we need so that we can
reconstruct and predict
individuals what we're doing here for
example we can get up to 90 percent
classification for we take in some of
this truck shaped and identify
individuals we
attention disorders we also tried it the
interesting thing is that that truck has
been a studying for years and we know is
related to attention and turns out
that's the track that comes out in the
closet best performance in
classification we also look at people
with bipolar disorders same way up to
90-percent classification and
schizophrenia so there's information in
across large populations and you need
you know be able to compute at this
level to actually address this question
this is brand very exciting work that
were riding up now is one of the other
projects being developed on the platform
brant looks at connections this one
connections between different parts of
the brain and these connections are been
studied for many years you know the way
these large work in neuroscience my lab
and other people's lab is that I'm
specializing connection someone else is
specializing function and some labs are
really good in memory some labs are
really good in language right and you
study how language changes over time in
aging and what we did here we took a
large datasets from Cambridge and we
actually try to put together many
domains or behaviors and many domains of
brain brain extracted from the networks
to try to predict the aging process of
individuals so this is the the results
that we have I'm very excited about this
so this is a canonical correlation plot
ok standard correlation correlates to
variables right here's that think about
correlating two domains ok
there's about 300 plus variables task
accuracy reaction times questionnaires
ratings right the come to these axes and
on these other axis we have brain
network statistics and what we're trying
to do we try and can I predict the aging
process of or can I predict the
behaviors of these individuals given the
property of their brain network and you
see from the shape of this correlation
actually it's pretty good it's 88 okay
now you see the color map there the
color map
is age of those individuals the color
map did not enter the model so the shape
of this plot is independent of the color
map we laid out the age on the
individuals without using age in the
model so we have a prediction actually
66 is the correlation pretty good
prediction of Aging
without using aging in today I'll it's a
classically one out approach very
excited about this work so to sum up can
we use these platforms to engage
scientist convince them that the shook
on it's valuable for them can improve
their work to come on this platform and
do something useful share the data share
their code commit that time to commit on
their code okay it's a thing that I see
as I go with graduate students they love
doing research and they're worried at
the beginning committing to what they've
done right this is a process that
probably in companies part of what you
do many time you just check the code
into code base right but that is not the
normal process in in academia in
academia everyone develops their own
little repository unless there's a
management style in the lab that is
different normally skills anyway so we
find the funding this is started with an
initial grant actually started with a
grant from the Big Data hub that led us
to develop the prototype and we use that
funding to then write a grant for the
brain initiative at on itself we got
that grant meanwhile with the help Bunny
we got some funding through a sewer in
the hub and these are all the
collaborators you Lindsey tan Brant
Nicholas Bradley Paulo and so eg was the
mastermind behind most of the
development thank you
[Applause]
so maybe we take a couple of questions
and maybe a comment about how all this
ties together and how the work that
Franco and team are doing on brain life
applies to the broader citizen science
work that we are being Microsoft are
trying to support that support from the
NSF do you have anything to say about
that so when I first saw this talk or a
version of it I was really impressed
this was at the the data science
workshop and I thought this is so
sensible you know this is one of the
stepping stones right this is the glue
that allows us to take data and
algorithms from different stakeholders
and and create workflows and ensure with
you know registration in a library and
metadata that there's compatibility
among these things and then these are
like tinker toys or Legos you know and
you can do research and you can move
them around and you can do a/b testing
and and I thought we need this for
human-machine partnerships too we need
to extend this into the space of crowd
powered systems and and again it's it's
these feedback loops you know we want to
take the crowd base data and then train
the machine learner to make it better
you know or figure out which which
architecture works best and and do this
in real time have dynamically improving
machine learners that are also
contributing to a broader analytic
platform so to make these kind of you
know living things that are self
improving always is one of the one of
the goals into and to reduce the amount
of the tremendous amount of time we and
students spend on trying to fit these
pieces together so so I mentioned this
to to Vani and and I spoke with Franco
about it
and and we decided it might be an
interesting idea to shop around and and
we've been shopping it around within and
without Microsoft and and so you know we
we we haven't publicly said so but we're
we were we're gonna pursue this in
earnest and we'd love to have everyone
in this room involved in some way in
making this a reality you can sort of
imagine that you know in one
instantiation you have a community
service provider like Zooniverse right
so what if you have a data set and you
want to analyze it in Zooniverse and
then you want to have somebody do
machine learning research on the stuff
coming back out of Zooniverse well now
these are all pieces in a system you
know Zooniverse has an api and and this
this system has an api and you can make
these things work together you can do
your a/b testing you can focus on the
science as opposed to the machinations
required to do the research itself so so
I'm very excited this is the first time
you know we've sort of shared this idea
in a group setting I'm thrilled to you
know be able to build on on franco's
excellent work and and and it's really a
pleasure to engage with Microsoft
Research and discovering just you know
the amazing work that's being done here
and I think this could all come together
in a really useful way for all of us and
for society and the name of this
framework is is Sevilla Sevilla ms the
Latin word for citizenry so anyway
that's my comment I was going to show
you the type of practical problem I
imagine when you start generating we so
for a conference in May we generate
about 250,000 brain images ok these are
actually 3d images coin clouds or
volumes ok and so they're more right
and on many of these we know we have
some artifacts and ideally we like to
have an API to publish we could publish
on CBM if we got some funding to develop
it we can publish on zum-zum nurse if we
if that's a possibility we're trying to
partner with with entities that are
interested in helping us write to go to
scale punishments seems great perishing
with the eye since also very valuable we
have basic eristic that we can implement
to identify some of the artifacts some
of them are really hard because we don't
have ballistics so if we do succeed and
engaging all these researchers into
analyze data and we start generating so
much data that it will be impossible to
do Quality Assurance on the data without
having partnership with some sort of
intelligent rely on individuals that's
why I hope we got to work together more
will still break for lunch at did you
have a question Lucy yeah yeah this is
fantastic you know it's really great to
hear about this I I guess so one you
know Devils in the details right and so
you know one of the things that
Zooniverse has been trying to work on
just with one project the large synoptic
survey telescope which is you know our
next big thing on the astrophysics side
so it's it's a hard process to convince
leadership of these large you know
billion-dollar enterprises like this to
get something like the Zooniverse
embedded early on into the data pipeline
but
managed it so that was hurdle number one
so when LSST goes online in the next you
know year or so there will be the
opportunity for scientists working with
LSST data to quote-unquote spin up a
Zooniverse project quote-unquote easily
okay again Devils in the details but but
the problem we're facing now is the
scientists and they're you know going
back to what you were saying how do we
convince the scientists that you know
even after all of the work we've done we
can show all these publication plots you
know we can show you know sometimes it's
it's just you know they don't know that
this type of thing infrastructure exists
if they did know about it then you know
they would avail themselves of it so so
really it's a question of how do we so
these a great fantastic idea awesome
let's do it but well you know how do we
get the news out how do we convert
scientists who feel somehow for a
variety of reasons you know they don't
want to put their data as you were
saying that's my data I don't want to
you know put my date or my you know
whatever or they're suspicious of having
the crowd involved in in the work then
that I have a comment to make about that
in the limited exposure that I've had in
this space over the last couple of years
or so I think one approach that could
work is start with the community
approach so where the community deeply
cares about a problem and then you go
and find the scientists who are working
on the problem and you take the
community's help in bringing the data on
to the platform and you take the
community's help in engaging citizen
scientists which is what you've done
with the snapshot Serengeti project and
that's this whole this there's a very
rich you know ecology ecosystem that you
have any able don't talk about
Zooniverse right so that approach tends
to be better I think then you know just
trying to ask scientists to contribute
just for the sake of reproducibility
of science or so on right so that I
think to show that there that there is a
problem that they are concerned about
that's being solved by this system right
so uh I just wanted to interject in this
conversation because I was really
excited before you made the announcement
about that idea of a platform and I
wanted to talk with you offline and I'm
glad now we can all do it online I think
it's amazing and I had a similar thought
to you with the question for you which
is that's great when we create the
platform but how do we create a
community and so when I you know I I'm
very excited about the space of human AI
partnerships and I'm exploring it for a
number of years now but I find I'm one
of the few people in my very large
community that's doing that and it feels
like we're all little islands and so
when I think of a platform emerging I
think that must may be must is too
strong but a good way to make sure that
it survives is to make sure that we
create a community and so my question is
have you thought about that and if so
what can we do towards that I don't know
how to work I think that's a that's an
excellent question and I think it's an
echo also of what Lucy was was
suggesting which is I mean there's this
there still today skepticism in the
community about getting members of the
general public to analyze data so I
think part of the the challenge here is
what I would call mainstreaming you know
where you know we're in a very AI
centric world today and I think having
you know a managed service having an
industry heavyweight like Microsoft
that's saying we you know we have this
thing Microsoft is behind this ooh you
mean oh if Microsoft thinks this is good
you know maybe maybe there's something
to this and and I and I think the work
we actually do I think bringing use
cases with high visibility into this
platform early is gonna draw her Mendes
media attention it's the new AI I mean
without calling it that it's it's always
been a sub-branch of AI and and so as
you get as you gather more media
attention and potentially controversy
which can be a
very good thing when you're trying to
generate visibility then you know these
questions come to the forefront and
people you know and scientists will will
will say I don't know you know I don't
trust the public to analyze the data
well now we have this platform that
allows us to demonstrate more
effectively and repeatedly how you can
effectively get even better data from
from a crowd than from an expert in our
own platform we've actually demonstrated
that to the chagrin actually to the
appreciation of the science the
scientist generating the data when they
said your data isn't your crowd is not
aligning with our analysis so we went we
sat down we looked at it they said Oh
your crowd is right so you know we need
more examples of that but I think it's I
think it's a good question it's it
always comes down to humans doesn't it
the challenge so the way we are
approaching this problem of engagement
it's multiple obviously but grass root
start from the students ok can now go to
the leaders of the projects you had to
start training young people so we
started making videos and we had lots
lots to do there we start of ready
self-organization the whole platform has
this idea that should be easy enough
that you can use it and there should be
short videos which are shows AMA that
give you an idea what to do I think it's
a cultural problem is not a scientific
problem that we're addressing and
presenting our conferences it's always
the best way to do we actually got good
attention in the last conference that
was the first time we presented the
platform so I think in euro science this
is coming NIH and NSF are requiring
changes for data management and to
sustain your project over time and and
yeah but definitely there's there has to
be multiple approaches not going to be
one solution fits all it's going to be
collaboration between labs visibility
partnerships in our worlds that
divisibility papers they give you
visibility we know which one those are
etc etc so it's going to be a mixture of
the old-style process plus a grassroot
approach or educating a new generation
student so on that note Franko when you
say educating the the new general are
these people who are scientists in other
Sciences other the computer science or
are they because I feel like there is
this gap as well that in computer
science with generally optimize for
ourselves we have no idea how our models
are going to be used by the other
scientific communities even now like
when we talk about human high
collaboration we talk about
collaboration where you know what you're
looking for but what you don't know as a
scientist what if you just want to look
at the data and who knows what comes out
of it like you might have an hypothesis
but something else come out and we don't
often design for that type of
collaboration so I've been trying to and
I might succeed in pitching to my
institution to teach a class called
neuroscience for data science the idea
of how do you understand the data which
for data scientists it's the file type
right or how you read it or what are the
questions that people might be asking
that a very simple overview what where
the brain is and what it does might be
enough to go a long way for it getting
some computer scientists interested in
in that type of data and there's a lot
of companies and there's a lot of good
that can come out of actually engaging
them into trying to understand the data
and clarify the data so that's one class
that can can happen it can happen in
different versions and the other class
should be probably a data science for
neuroscientist because definitely our
generations on graduate student in
psychology neuroscience they need to
become more proficient in computing
because things are getting out of hands
for them because the algorithms are
becoming more and more complicated and
the stack of software is becoming more
and more more complicated so
you know in my small world it is what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to teach a
class in the engineering computer
science that teach them how to handle
and know anything that people are doing
in your science and and then teaching
them in psychology and neuroscience know
um I'm happy to start so I I mean full
disclosure I have a paper on your review
about this I'm gonna go ahead and spill
the beans on that one I think that
there's been so many individual islands
of people proposing human AI
partnerships and simply surveyed and
categorizing them and perhaps putting
them all within the same platform online
allows us to start thinking about these
work clothes any you know it becomes
very formalized as a computer scientist
I was trained in abstract patterns about
like if I want to program for different
scenarios I can go and get these
abstract models I think it should be the
exact same thing for human AI
partnerships where we have these
abstract models we know about them
different people are doing this in
different communities and if we can put
them together and put them on a platform
all of a sudden we start to have this
mix-and-match space where we can start
to think about what's not being
represented there and move forward as a
community so I think the first yeah the
first task is just taking toll and
putting that together and if I were to
push that to the next task is when we
have these abstract patterns of
partnerships then each group can talk
about where the scenario they can talk
about how is the performance of those
patterns on their own data right so you
know as humans love to do categorize
that's how we make sense of the world
right and but I also want to this is
kind of a tangential bias but one of the
biases I have come up against is in
working with people who specialize in
machine learning and when we're sitting
down to try to develop the best combined
AI with humans there is there they're
very arrogant and they say oh we don't
need the humans but we can just you know
we don't need the Zooniverse
volunteers for this because we just you
know object detection is a solved thing
and we don't need any validation of the
object labels anymore we don't you know
we're done with that stuff we don't need
the humans anymore and I keep trying to
push back and say you know but you can
actually improve you know and so you
know there's the sort of retraining or
rethinking from the use of AI bubble
right I couldn't agree with you more
because at some point that type of
thinking is gonna burst and they are
gonna be confronted with this stage
where you can't you know you really do
need the humans in the loop and to try
to retrain the computer scientists to
think more about I don't have to get the
most accurate model somebody said I
think AJ said this you know I don't have
to get the most accurate I just what is
best what is best mean until going full
circle in your categorization project
how can we kind of provide sort of a
reference point of you know what's best
if I if I have a machine model that
works you know it's confidence is not as
good as the next one but the next one
requires a huge amount of attention in
in fine-tuning and is really brittle and
is gonna break on the next you know set
of data you pass through it so these
kinds of metrics that I think we really
have to use in in your categorization
project if I'm you know thinking about
it the way you were trying to think
about it so as someone who comes from
the computer science discipline I don't
know who you're talking to but I already
when I heard you say the response you
get had a sense of why it was being said
and so when people say it's a solved
problem and I I probably use that too
when I talk to people it says that if I
as a researcher were to approach that it
wouldn't be interesting
not novel and new and I think the
challenge is how do we create and
understand it and I like your idea of
evaluation metrics and then more than
that it's also how do we reveal what's
challenging and new and until we show
for a computer science community that
these issues are generalized it's not
about one data set but we look across
all these many data sets and we see the
same trend emerge I think that's how you
attract a community of people who are
gonna do algorithm research because it
says this isn't a one-off this isn't
just an outlier this is an interesting
problem and I think it's an onus of
people who are trying to promote human
AI partnerships as an important problem
to study that we we have to prove that
this is it's a general problem and until
we do that I think we're always going to
get pushback from the mainstream hard
core algorithm people to say look that's
great it's solved because we know in
most cases you get enough train data
it's solved I'll just be quick and then
I just wanted to add to especially this
kind of notion of hubris among
researchers that you occasionally you
know run into and you know I mean I
think it comes from a good place I think
it's it's you know there there there
there is kind of a fervor which can be a
scary thing but there's a fervor around
just you know some of these the these
very tantalizing results that we see in
ml but I think you know having you know
being able to spin out more examples of
places where you know even with infinite
training data the ml isn't just is just
not getting there is is gonna help kind
of catalyze appreciation maybe even
among machine learning researchers for
pure machine learning researchers for
the value of doing it this way and and I
think stock catchers is a great case
study and and we're gonna you know
publish on this topic but the first
question we asked is why can't I said I
was going to be brief
yeah self-report is awful so the first
thing we ask is can the can the machine
do it and and we really kind of went
through the rigors to make sure that
though the machine only gets at
eighty-five percent right so then we
already know we have a reason to use a
crowd but then it introduces the
question of why and I think you know
when when machine learning researchers
can start to realize the value of that
to be able to understand well why is it
that humans can do this at 99% and the
machine can only do it at 85% than that
that creates a new target you know
hopefully a qualitatively new target for
machine learning or AI research and in
our case it's it's about real-world
knowledge
physics you know fluid dynamics because
you're looking at these blood vessels
sometimes they're overexposed you just
can't tell if it's flowing or not but if
you look at surrounding vessels and the
flow patterns and you can see the
network you realize that if it's moving
here
there's nothing flowing here and there's
something coming out here it has to be
moved even if you can't tell you know
because as a child you played with a
garden hose so that means okay so now we
have to build this kind of knowledge
into an AI it sets a new trajectory for
a I actually changed what I wanted to
say listening to yeah so that was
actually useful I you know I think it is
kind of misleading to present this in
science platforms to ml researchers or
AI researchers as a platform for data I
think the collaboration needs to be much
closer and stronger than that because
you know as somebody who's been playing
a lot with the citizen science data I
usually have a very hard time to know
what is the goal of the scientists what
are they really trying to accomplish
because most of the time it is not
getting some accuracy number to a level
it is finding the cases that do not fit
to the current economy these surprises
or you know maybe it is not be curious
the number doesn't have a meaning but
they
have a goal with this data and we really
try to get to the data objective and I
think we have to figure out a way to
connect the scientists who are
benefitting with these platforms to the
people who really want to use this data
to solve a real problem with AI and
somehow have that collaboration much
stronger between the two sides right
exactly and so you know going back to
your point earlier about well you know
it's a solved problem means it's not
interesting to an AI person and you know
what idea is saying and what I also
think it's okay but well several things
but so when you involve humans in the
loop and AI is changing as fast as it's
changing right so you will get into
these situations where there will be you
know that from the AI researcher
perspective it's like oh well that's
just a solved problem but the scientist
is like I don't care if that's a solved
problem from the AI perspective I just
need the tool that is gonna get me the
thing that I want most and and it's
sometimes it's this disconnect between
the science scientists being able to
express his or her goals and the AI
specialist saying well your goals as
novel research aren't the same as my
goals as novel research so this isn't an
interesting problem for me to be working
on you know it's how to convince kind of
both sides that maybe from the
scientists perspective the data that the
AI researcher is interested in isn't
necessarily interesting for the
scientist and and and vice versa so it's
really narrowing in on what you know
what are the two sides one out of each
other how do we define this relationship
so both get something out of it I know
that was a bit rambley but that was you
know can I follow up and I think I think
I'm on right actually this is precisely
what should be happening
you asking us like we should be getting
into rooms and having collaboration
right you asking us what do you guys ask
right and I should ask you how do i
ingest my data into your system right so
I should be asking question that I don't
know about the engineering and you
should be asking questions that you
don't know about the science that we ask
so we need to have engagement point and
you know workshops you to start I think
has to be continuous and long lasting
more than a workshop problem and so I
think your point is I agree with what
you're saying which is it's how do you
align the value like the goals of the
two communities and I would actually
like to go further and say that I think
that people have already proposed
solutions that seem like it could be a
good fit for that so I don't know if you
fall a little gaggle okay so cackles one
place that's kind of tried to solve it
but they didn't go all the way and my
collaborators actually spun off a new
company that in the past year which is
actually a place where prospective
employers post data and someone's talk
actually talked about this kind of model
but you post data and then people who
are interested in getting a job at the
place to come and they compete in this
data set challenge and then at the point
that they compete if their work is good
enough then they might get a chance to
get an interview and get a job and so I
teach students introduction to machine
learning and they're eager to get jobs
and a lot of them are would you know
they'd be delighted to work in a lab and
so if you have people posting data where
it could turn into employment you're
gonna I think you would find that lots
of students and people looking for jobs
might land in the right place I don't
think researchers are going to be
convinced - yeah I think that it would
be harder to sell to AI researcher to
come and work on these kind of problems
but I think there's so many people who
would dive in these problems and I think
it's the next generation of students and
if that was something that happened
frankly I would have my students I'd it
every year they get to choose a project
and I know a whole bunch of them would
probably choose to take data sets firm
scientists because that's a really cool
story to tell
it might turn into a job when they're
done hi
so coming back to Donna's fine I
previously worked at a start-up where we
were trying out I mean one of the ideas
was to try this model where we would
post data on a platform and have people
come and take part in the challenge to
offer a job but I think one of the
issues are like the points that was
raised was how ethical is this like we
have people having you know you're
getting people to work on your data and
is promising an interview enough of a
you know reward for the work that
they've done and we run into some issues
that I think surround us and I think
that's an interesting one just yeah I
think Tippie that's a excellent point
and and so I mean I think an inevitable
consequence of the rapid proliferation
of human and loop systems is going to
have a concomitant rapid proliferation
of ethical questions so I think yeah we
need a conscience committee you know to
watch that and and I'm glad you you you
raised that and I and I wonder you know
sort of getting back to you know this
question of creating collaborations and
the quid pro quo and it you know just
because it's a win for you doesn't mean
it's a win for me I wonder if if having
a platform or framework like sybian
takes a step toward addressing that in
the sense that you end up with artifacts
that are produced so if if I'm if I'm a
researcher with data and I want to do
some kind of machine learning analysis I
can go and find art of machine learning
artifacts and and apply them directly
without having to fully understand you
know the inner workings of those things
or or similarly you know if I want to
if I have a MOOC you know so so there's
this concept of a serve a community
provider survive a MOOC that's a
community and if I can build an API that
that ties into this then I can draw data
that serves whatever educational purpose
my MOOC has from there and in the
process you know data are getting
analyzed and getting fed back in and
someone else might come along and and
you know you're you're trashes my what's
the expression one person's treasure
treasure treasure Thank You treasure so
I think that we should wrap up thank you
for your comments everyone I think this
is a really good group of people to get
together it feels more like executive
briefing session than hoe workshop so
yeah on behalf of beside myself thank
you so much for your talks today and for
the rich discussion lunch is served
outside you can bring your lunch back in
here or is it in the main room I guess I
should know it's in McKinley it's in the
main room where the meals for the
conference were so you can continue
discussions over there yeah you should
move with them you should wrap up from
this room thank you